SETH LADD: Welcome to this
episode of Dartisans.
Today we are talking continuous
integration testing
and deployment with Dart,
everyone's favorite structured
web programming language.
Today, special guest with us,
the founders of Drone I/O, Tom
Burke and Brad Rydzewski.
Thank you, guys, so much
for coming in.
Drone I/O is a continuous
integration service that
supports Dart out of the box,
and they're here today to show
us a variety of different use
cases and functions that you
can use with your Dart projects
for continuous
integration testing
and deployment.
Thanks, guys, for joining us.
BRAD RYDZEWSKI: Thanks
for having us.
SETH LADD: Really
appreciate it.
So I'm really curious, how did
you get into and interested in
continuous integration?
BRAD RYDZEWSKI: So it started
probably a few months ago.
We spent three or four days
setting up a Jenkins server,
and we thought, there's got
to be a better way.
SETH LADD: And define for
me continue integration.
I feel like this is something
that has a lot
of different meanings.
What does it mean to
you and Drone?
BRAD RYDZEWSKI: So it's the
ability to, as you're making
changes to your code,
automatically test them to
find your bugs immediately, and
notify your team members.
Bugs are a lot easier
to fix that way.
And then, there's some nice
things you can do in terms of
automated deployments, which
are a huge time saver.
SETH LADD: So what attracted
you to Dart?
Drone supports many languages,
Ruby, Python, Go, I think I
saw SCALA in there,
what about Dart?
BRAD RYDZEWSKI: So we were
huge fans of Google Web
Toolkit and very active in that
community, and we also
use Go very heavily, so we
were very excited to add
another Google technology
to our stack.
SETH LADD: And I feel like
continuous integration is even
more important for new and
upcoming systems like Dart
that have a lot of milestone
releases very quickly.
I think it's important for
us, as Dart authors and
developers, to stay on top of
the continual changes and
upgrades to the Dart
ecosystem.
So getting your package and
code into Drone can really
help you get notified when
say, libraries change or
evolve, your dependencies
change, and so I continuous
integration almost
as a requirement
for the Dart developer.
BRAD RYDZEWSKI: Absolutely,
Drone will always test your
code against the latest version
of Dart, so you can
always make sure that it's using
the latest and greatest
language features, and that
you don't have any syntax
issues or anything like that.
SETH LADD: Perfect.
Well, let's see some demos.
So I think first off, probably
the most primary use case is I
have some unit tests
for my project.
How do I make sure that I can
have Drone run all these, and
tell me if they're
working or not?
BRAD RYDZEWSKI: Sure, so let's
switch to the screen, and
we're looking at just the most
basic Dart unit test.
It's going to test the function
that adds two numbers.
And this simple project is
checked into GitHub, so now,
what we're going to do is we're
going to import this
into Dart and run the unit
test so let's log in.
And no need to create username
and password.
You can log in with
your GitHub,
Bitbucket or Google ID.
So I'm going to go ahead and log
in with my GitHub account.
So we're going to start by
creating a new project.
And this, like I said before,
this was in GitHub, and so we
see our list of GitHub
projects here.
SETH LADD: I love this because
you don't have to type in any
repository name.
This is auto discovering all
of your repositories.
That's cool.
BRAD RYDZEWSKI: So we're going
to click Drone Demo here, and
what this is doing now in the
background is it added your
project to Drone, and then it
also set up a build hook so
that every time you make and
commit a code change, Drone
I/O is automatically going
to build it for you.
So, of course, we're going to
select Dart as the language.
Now, it's going to prompt us
to enter in a build script.
Now, this is where you may have
to edit it, based on your
actual code.
So I'm going to go ahead
and change this to
run the unit test.
It's in a file called
test runner.
SETH LADD: So I see here, that
this might be project specific
for the short term, but I think
more in term on the
radar of the Dart team is some
sort of build tool with
well-defined tasks
and targets.
One of those, of course, would
be run all my unit test, so I
think this is going to get even
easier as we go further
in the project.
BRAD RYDZEWSKI: That
would be great.
Now, we'll go ahead
and save this.
Project is now saved.
You can do a lot more to modify
your build script.
You can set up databases.
You can either change the
version of Dart you want to
test against.
For now we're just going to
test against the standard
version of Dart.
Now I'm going to kick off the
build manually so we can see
[INAUDIBLE].
SETH LADD: So what's happening
when you click that button?
BRAD RYDZEWSKI: So when I
click that button, it's
checking out your code to a
fresh virtual machine running
the commands that
we specified.
Now we're looking at the
build output that is
displayed in real time.
You can see all the tests
passed and you can
[INAUDIBLE].
SETH LADD: So I pulled down the
code from GitHub, spawned
a VM inside your build cluster,
ran the commands that
you put into that text field.
And then it puts
out the output.
That was really quick.
BRAD RYDZEWSKI: Yes, yeah,
very easy to get started.
SETH LADD: Very nice.
So not everybody has unit tests,
although of course we
encourage everybody
to do unit tests.
We've started shifting unit
tests and in the box libraries
out of box.
What can you offer our Dart
developers who don't yet have
unit tests in their projects but
still want to get notified
if say libraries are changing
[INAUDIBLE].
BRAD RYDZEWSKI: Absolutely.
So a great tool utility
is Dart Analyzer.
So Dart Analyzer will check
syntax, it wil check if you're
using specific [INAUDIBLE].
If you're taking advantage of
the optimum [INAUDIBLE] of the
feature within Dart.
So let's go ahead and import a
project and we can test out
the Dart Analyzer.
So we'll go to the new setup
page and choose GitHub.
We're going to go to
this to do list.
And again, we're going
to choose Dart.
And this time I'm going
to change the
script to use Dart Analyzer.
SETH LADD: Now, as you're
typing, that Dart analyzer is
a tool written in Java right now
that will analyze all of
your Dart code, and again, look
at the optional types and
see if you have anything that
looks a little fishy, if you
will, things may not match
up quite perfectly.
It will give you warnings about
potential misuses of types.
Really, really good tool that
give you heads up on the
status of your product.
BRAD RYDZEWSKI: So I've modified
the script to run
Dart Analyzer, let's go
ahead and save this.
And now, again, we'll run
the build manually.
This is dumping us into
the real time output.
SETH LADD: Now, how did you
get the real time output?
BRAD RYDZEWSKI: So this
is using web sockets.
SETH LADD: Oh, that's awesome.
BRAD RYDZEWSKI: And so you can
see here, we get a ton of
great output of specific
warnings that Dart Analyzer
has targeted.
So now, we can use this
to improve our code.
SETH LADD: So what
triggers a--
I get the sense in CI
terminology, builds are either
green or red?
Does Drone have green,
red, and is there
this concept of yellow?
That is, how do you interpret
this kind of output?
I mean, the code may still work,
but I may want to take
action on this, so how do you
surface that to the user?
BRAD RYDZEWSKI: Correct.
So right now, Dart Analyzer
always outputs with a status
of zero, so we use the exit
code of the command you're
running to determine if Dart
should show a red or green.
In this case, because Dart
Analyzer returned and exit
code of zero, that's why
you see a green.
So what you could do is you
could analyze the output as
part of your build
configuration.
You may be able to grep the
output and trigger an exit
status of one if
you wanted to.
SETH LADD: Cool.
So out of the box you can run
the command, but then it's up
to us to interpret these
warnings or errors
appropriately based on my own
personal threshold for say,
type usage.
BRAD RYDZEWSKI: Yes.
SETH LADD: Great.
Very cool.
OK, good.
So we've seen examples, I think,
on more like command
line driven applications, but
I'm really curious, most of
Dart is really targeted at
building dynamic web apps and
run in the browser.
Does Drone I/O have anything
to help us test
browser-based apps?
BRAD RYDZEWSKI: Absolutely.
So if we look at the screen
right now, we're going to go
to this To Do app.
And we're going to look
at two specific files.
So the To Do app,
this is actually
from the game of Darts.
We took the To Do app and we
modified it a little bit to
add in some unit testing.
And since this is a client
side web app, we actually
wanted to unit test the DOM.
We wanted to make sure that
we're adding elements, we
added error messaging if you're
to do list is too long.
So we wanted to make sure we're
showing or hiding the
error message correctly,
and we've added unit
tests for all of that.
So what you can see here is all
of these simple unit tests
use the Dart HTML package.
They test to see certain
classes are added
appropriately or the element
text is set correctly when
there's an error et cetera.
So a lot of times, the way you
would run browser-based tests
is you would create an HTML
file, and you would link to a
unit test file that you've added
a main method to that
invokes your unit tests.
Very similar if you've done
JS Unit in the past.
It'll load up the web page and
run your Dart unit test in the
context of the web page.
So the question is, how do you
do something like this from a
command line or in a continuous
integration
solution like Drone?
So Dart has a great utility
called Dump Render Tree.
Dump Render Tree is a headless
version of Chrome.
It allows you to run your unit
test from the command line and
it will output them to the
command line so that we can
look at the output
and analyze it.
So in this sample project, this
one that we just ran, we
actually set up a Dump
Render Tree test.
So we'll replace Dart Analyzer
with Dump Render Tree.
SETH LADD: Now, do all Dart
Drone builds get Dump Render
Tree out of the box or is this a
separate config that I would
have to do?
BRAD RYDZEWSKI: So this is a
separate config that you would
have to do.
And I can pull that up next.
We added a shell script that
will invoke the unit tests via
Dump Render Tree.
SETH LADD: Now, as your typing,
I should mention Dump
Render Tree, like
Brad said, is a
headless version of Chrome.
We also have, it's essentially a
headless version of Dartium,
which is Chromium with a
Dart virtual machine.
And this again, is open source
like everything else we're
doing here, or at least in the
Dart world, and you can get
Dump Render Tree as a
separate download.
But, of course, Drone I/O
is going to pack--
provides this for free for you,
which is really cool.
BRAD RYDZEWSKI: And so one thing
we need to do in our
build script that's important,
is we need an X Windows server
to be running inside of
our virtual machine.
So I'm going to do
pseudo start.
And that will start up a
virtual frame buffer.
I'm going to save the
build script.
Now, we're going to go
ahead and run this.
So we see the real
time output.
And what you can see
here is the output
of Dump Render Tree.
So it's actually dumping some
of the elements and their
positions in the browser.
You can see that in
the command line.
You can actually see the output
of the unit tests are
Dart unit tests so it passed
showing and hiding various
elements, et cetera.
SETH LADD: No, walk me through
this a little bit.
So it's still doing the standard
my codes in GitHub.
It's going to pull or clone
the repo there.
Now, where does it get Dump
Render Tree from?
Do you have a local
cache of that?
BRAD RYDZEWSKI: Yes.
So Dump Render Tree is included
when you download the
Dart Editor.
The Dump Render Tree executable
with binaries included.
That's downloaded automatically
into the virtual
machine where you're running
your Dart unit test and it's
part of the path.
So you can invoke Dump
Render Tree directly.
SETH LADD: That's probably
why this is so fast.
You've already download the
environment that we need and
it's all ready to go.
So you've done all this
really great work.
We set up a bunch of projects
here to set up continuous
integrations, how do we brag to
the world that we've done
this, we know all the time
whether my project is
succeeding or not?
BRAD RYDZEWSKI: So I'm going
to pass this off to Tom.
TOM BURKE: Thanks.
So one really easy and effective
way to do that is
through what we call
Build Status Badge.
So I've just pulled up one of
our projects that's in GitHub
that has it.
So you can see right here it
says, passing on Drone I/O.
And all you have to do to get
this for one of your projects
is you go into Drone I/O, you
go to your Project Settings,
and under Badges, we give
you a couple of links.
And these are just links that
you can put on your home page
of your project or
the mark down.
So if you have a read me MD
file in PUB or GitHub or
Bitbucket, you would simply just
cut and paste this right
into your read me.
And then, from there on, every
time a build kicks off, this
will automatically
change the image.
SETH LADD: I love that.
And so if you put it in the read
me of your project, it
shows up, not only in GitHub as
you're seeing here, but now
PUB, which hosts or can host
packages for Dart, also can
display the read me, and so you
get your badge basically
anywhere your read me is,
which is really cool.
TOM BURKE: And it's nice too.
If you click on the badge, it
takes you right to the latest
build output that generated
that status.
SETH LADD: So you mentioned
continuous integration is much
more than just testing, right?
There's a whole bunch of
post-testing workflow steps.
One, probably most important,
is deploy, and I think Drone
can also drive a deploy
step, too.
Can you show us how I might,
after tests have succeeded,
what else I can do
with my code?
TOM BURKE: One of the things we
find extremely productive
is to automate our
deployments.
So if you go to your project
in drone, and you go to
Services, you'll notice there's
a couple of deployment
targets right now.
So right now, I'll just show you
how to deploy to Heroku.
Now, to deploy to Heroku, you'll
have to have a Drone
application that has both a
server and a client part.
So I'm just going to pull
up a sample right here.
Really, the first step to
getting your Dart application
ready for Heroku is you have to
listen on a very specific
address and port.
So in the case of Heroku, it's
IP address 0000 and they're
going to pass in the port
parameter and an
environmental variable.
SETH LADD: So let's be
really clear about
what's happening here.
So Dart, of course, is a
language that compiles to
JavaScript for modern browser
deployments, but also runs in
its own virtual machine.
And once you have your own
virtual machine, you can run
that anywhere.
You can run that, of course,
in the browser, but you can
run it on the server.
And so that's what's actually
powering this.
We're going to put the Dart VM,
which runs a web server
here, onto Heroku.
TOM BURKE: Yeah.
Yeah, so its Heroku running the
web server, serving the
client, which is also written
in Dart, and in the case of
the demo I'm showing you, I
pulled the countdown clock
from the Dart SDK samples.
So you're going to make this
change and check your code.
And then you would go to the
command line and run a couple
of Heroku commands
to create an app.
So I'm just--
can I do that right here?
So the first command, and
Heroku has got great
documentation, I'm not going
to do much on this.
You just run a Heroku create
your app name, and this
complained about a name that
was already taken, so I'll
just run that again.
And then, I'm going to go to one
that I've already done a
little bit of the set up.
So you create your app, then
you-- because it Dart--
Heroku requires you to
have what we call
a Dart build pack.
So that's this command
here, Heroku config
add, the build pack.
SETH LADD: And the build pack is
actually what connects your
Dart source code to
the Dart virtual
machine and its run time.
TOM BURKE: Yeah, it explains
to Heroku what to do if
someone deploys a Dart
based app to it.
All right, so I did that.
Now, you have your Heroku app
created at this point.
It's set up to work with Dart.
The issue now is how
do we get Drone to
communicate with Heroku?
So to do that, we go back into
Drone, you pull up your
project, you go to Services,
Heroku, you download the
deployment key.
So I'm going to click that right
now and that downloaded
a deployment key to my laptop.
Now, I go back into where I
created my app and I run the
simple command to add the key
I just downloaded, so this
uploads an SSH key to Heroku,
and, at this point, what this
means is Drone should be
able to deploy your app
automatically.
So the last step back in Drone
is make sure that in the
Heroku deployment, it gives
a URL for Heroku.
And I'm going to paste in the
one I just created and Save.
Now, when I go to Build, this
is going to, again, like
Brad's previous demos, it's
going to take your code, check
it out to a clean VM, and then,
if you had unit tests,
assuming they pass, it will
then proceed to push this
whole thing out to Heroku.
SETH LADD: That's awesome.
So it won't deploy unless
everything is working, which
is the whole idea.
That's great.
I think what it's doing now is
it's actually downloaded the
Dart SDK and submerging it up
with the code that you're
actually getting from GitHub,
or in this case, the Heroku
Get repository.
TOM BURKE: So this finished.
So in the build output, Heroku
actually gives you a little
link to the app you just
deployed, so I'm just going to
pull that up in the browser
to show you.
So you can see this is
the countdown clock.
SETH LADD: That's awesome.
TOM BURKE: Server side
in Dart, serving
a Dart-based client.
That's pretty cool how easy
it is to get that working.
SETH LADD: That was great.
So you start with the code in
GitHub and you add some tests,
and then you configure it into
Drone, which then runs the
test, so that works, so you
published into Heroku.
And then, you can show the
badge right back on your
project, and it seems like a
whole life cycle here can be
driven off of Drone.
And it Dart every step.
TOM BURKE: One last part I was
going to mention about
deploying to Heroku.
If you're developing in Dart,
you are often going to need to
run Dart to JS as part of making
an app that's usable by
more than just Dartium.
So it's really easy to
do, again, in Drone.
So right now, we just had PUB
installed, but there's this
little snippet of code,
and we'll share this.
If you just add this to your
build script in Drone, it runs
Dart to JS, which creates some
new JavaScript files.
And then a couple Git commands,
take those new files
and add them, commit them,
because Heroku uses Git also,
so this is going to commit them
and then deploy your app
on the next build with all
the JavaScript files
automatically generated.
SETH LADD: That's awesome.
And I think that this is going
to get a little bit easier
when we have again, this kind
of prescriptive build tool,
and we can build targets so an
open source community can
introduce their own targets, to
help with this to make it a
little bit more terse,
which is cool.
TOM BURKE: And this is, again,
this is just the real time
output showing it pushing
to Heroku.
SETH LADD: Very cool.
Wow, so we saw a lot of awesome
demos and it was so
quick, it's almost too easy.
Great work.
So what else is coming up
for Dart and Drone?
What's on your road map?
BRAD RYDZEWSKI: So
a couple things.
We've got a big release coming
up, and one of the things that
we're looking to provide is the
ability to automatically
build your or automatically
trigger your builds every time
a new version of Dart
is available.
So proactively.
So let's say, for example, when
the new weekly release
comes out, it'll automatically
build all your Drone projects
for you, and let you know
if there's any issues.
SETH LADD: Now, that's huge,
because as we near 1.0, we're
making all the changes now.
So we're kind of in a bumpy spot
right now, and so to have
this kind of proactive build
system all hooked up to the
analyzer unit tests, can tell
you ahead of time what you
need to do to stay on top of
these Dart releases as we get
to that 1.0 milestone.
BRAD RYDZEWSKI: Absolutely.
The second thing we want
to do is deeper
integration with PUB.
So you saw how we could auto
deploy a web application with
Heroku, but we want
to support people
developing libraries too.
So one thing that we can do is
when your build passes and all
your unit tests are successful,
we can actually
published to PUB automatically
for you.
And PUB will always have
the latest and
greatest of your code.
SETH LADD: Again, more
of the life cycle.
I really like it.
Well, how do I sign
up for Drone?
What do I get out of the box?
How do I get started?
BRAD RYDZEWSKI: So you could
just go to Drone.IO.
It's free, completely free,
for open source projects.
So it works with GitHub,
like you saw.
It also works with Bitbucket
and Google code.
And then, if you have private
projects that you would like
to build, it also works with
that and it's cheaper than
hosting your own Jenkins and
much easier to get started.
SETH LADD: That's for sure.
Awesome, so highly recommended
to all the Dart authors out
there, and not just for Dart,
of course, if you're running
any open source project or
private project, and you need
continuous integration,
check out Drone.
They're definitely
on the edge.
Thanks, guys, for coming in.
Go to Drone.IO to learn more,
and we thank you for watching
this episode of Dartisans.
We'll see you in the Dart
mailing list, Stack Overflow,
and Google+, and thanks
for watching.
We'll see you next time.
Thanks, guys.